[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre du logement et de la ville lors
de l'examen de la loi et l'enjeu vous
interpeller sur de nombreuses
dispositions qui allait conduire à une
grave crise du logement et du bâtiment
en 2021 je ne me suis pas trompé
monsieur le ministre en cette fin
d'année le marché du logement neuf et
durablement affecté l'offre à la vente
baisse de 14% le stock est inférieur à 9
mois
la délivrance des permis de construire
dans le collectif chute à -25% en
conséquence les prix augmentent de 4 7%
la fédération des promoteurs parle d'un
immense gâchis pour les logements
sociaux plus grave la baisse des appels
et la réduction à juste du loyer de
solidarité font chuter de 12% depuis
la consommation des agréments de
financement qui sont les permis de
construire de demain et les ouvertures
de chantier d'après demain pour
l'accession à la propriété
la fin programmée du ptz sous sa forme
actuelle provisoirement sauvé par la
majorité sénatoriale entraînera une
nouvelle baisse de la construction
si vous ne changez rien nous auront
mécaniquement perdu cinquante mille
construction en trois ans et les nuages
s'accumulent pendant ce temps là le
crédit immobilier va devenir de plus en
plus rare la banque de france eux
souhaitent les prescriptions
environnementales sont de plus en plus
drastiques et aboutissent adp lui qui
supprime des centaines d'hectares de
construction bref les années 2020 2022
vont connaître un décrochage de la
construction on n'attend pas plus de 385
milles mises en chantier en 2021 et du
temps du plan borloo que j'ai eu
l'honneur de mettre en oeuvre on en
avait 4 190 mille cent mille
construction de moi monsieur le ministre
c'est 250 mille emplois de moins dans le
bâtiment ma question est donc simple
envisagez vous un plan de relance pour
faire face à ce sujet comme nous l'avons
fait avec succès en 2008